hey everyone we are back we have a
against Alette Indy bio still talking to
all these great founders we are sitting
down now with matthias via hello hi how
are you thank you thank you very much
from be flow yeah hell yeah we're doing
I'm fantastic
I love biotech really yeah why because
it's a code of life it's true and I used
to mentor and I still you know I love I
love Indy bio so that's great yeah let's
let's let's dive into this so right all
right
is it true that one third of all plants
on a food on earth is pollinated by bees
is that about what it is yes that's true
one third one third or you want to see
the in the opposite way
70% of worldwide crops of all the crops
in the world need bee pollination to
produce fruits and seeds 70% need need
bee pollination yeah need we pretty much
know so hey we wouldn't have that's cool
avocados cherries Islands blueberries we
wouldn't have if you don't have bees so
we need these are very important things
work and what what exactly is it that
the bee does with the crops so here's
the plant the seed is growing the plants
growing and then the bee goes
hangs out by some flowers some you know
stamen get some of the what do they get
they put in to put it in their fur and
in their face and they bring it to the
plant
yeah and the plant is that Marla yeah
what I do is these are going are looking
for nectar and pollen in flowers because
that's the their their food right nectar
is carbohydrates it's kind of a sugar
and pollen is protein that they take
back to their home to their we have to
feed the brood and keep population
developing and also produce honey right
but by doing so without being conscious
about that they're pollinating flowers
what point Asian means they're gonna
give you an example on blueberry flowers
for example you know the blueberry the
you buy in the grocery store each
blueberry had a flower before a
blueberry right and what bees do is they
transport pollen from the male part of
the flower to the female one in order to
develop a fruit the more pollen that is
deposited in a flower in the female part
of the flower means the more seeds that
are being produced and the more seeds
that are produced the bigger the
blueberry so when you see a small blue
berry or a big bee very or when you see
a big apple or a small upper that's
because of the amount of seeds that that
food has and that's because of bees I
love that yeah so the size of the fruit
has to do with the amount of pollen that
the be brought to the plants exactly
that's cool and so and so then wait so
on are like a blueberry plant where is
the female and where is the mail and
then how does the bee move it this the
blueberry flower has the male and the
female part in the same same area same
area but and wind doesn't do enough yeah
wind usually it's either wind if you
don't have bees you can have production
but it's very low in comparison to
having bees working there that's cool
yeah yeah this is perfect segue into B
flow yeah because okay so you guys bring
the bees on site to increase the yields
yeah tell us we are you know the bee
pollination industry is a very old
industry where farmers are calling
beekeepers to rent their beehives and
pollinate their crops
however this industry has remained the
same for decades
there hasn't been any innovations or
technologies applied to be a pollination
to increase yields so what we're doing
is we're applying technologies into bees
we are feeding bees with organic
molecules compounds to enhance their
immune system and make them work more
hours even under cold weather yeah
that's true you're making these work
harder yeah and you know why they work
harder
because they're stronger stronger
they're healthier than than a bead that
has a week in your system so you made a
proprietary molecule that you feed the
bees yeah and the bees have boosted
immune system yes they're able to work
harder less disease you said as well
also less death than less it more
healthy yeah Wow you know one of the
biggest challenges that farmers are
having today is cold weather conditions
bees usually don't work and they start
working probably after 55 degrees so
farmer's work they don't go out of their
behalf under 55 Fahrenheit they don't go
yeah so what we're doing is and that's
happening that's making that farmers
maybe lose some hours in the day where
there's no pollination happening so what
we're doing is by developing stronger
bees by feeding them with this product
we're making them stronger and they
start working at 45 degrees for example
so by doing so our pollen is being
transported in the field yes and crop
yields are been increased yes also what
we do is we're filling bees with other
product that is an organic molecules
compounds that what we're doing is we're
training bees to pollinate specific
Terra crops yes
we're training them whoa so you can make
blueberry bees and strawberry bees yeah
it's with the same base we can condition
bees memory yeah similar to the Pavlov
theory yeah the one of the dog yeah
right so we can make the bees for a
couple of days between 10 and 15 days we
can condition their memory and make them
focus exclusively on Wilbury flowers
instead of getting distracted by other
flowers yeah so one of the biggest
inefficiency that that farmers are are
dealing with today is they put because
they're from the beekeepers but bees go
everywhere it's legal for nectar and so
look you know you put Facebook out there
instead of just sending a direct message
between people you're now you're just
scrolling through your newsfeed
distracted
they yeah it's very funny so beehives
will just kill have bees go wherever
instead of target focused on certain
things that you need yep
so now we're making the bees work for us
not just have them go by random what
happens is there hasn't been like a deep
understanding on bees biology to tackle
these inefficiencies yes so by
understanding bees biology and how they
interact with flowers is that we are
developing strong and smart bees as we
call them awesome
you're from Argentina yeah from Buenos
Aires yes so Argentina has a crazy
biotech push is that true yeah that's
true
yeah yeah we're having the reason is
because we have a very strong academia
and we had two Nobel prizes in science
and we have a very strong community of
researchers and our researchers are very
well known in the world and we have very
good universities and institutions doing
research so we see a lot of potential on
Argentina being a leader in the
biotechnology space I'm really happy to
hear that yeah I thought I'd go down one
of my friends was just there staying for
a couple months I have to go down and
explore myself well yeah good that's oh
that's very important to hear that some
biotech increase is happening in
Argentina so what are some other aspects
you were talking about both training the
bees understanding the biology to be to
be able to train it to increase its
health what are there other aspects yeah
what we also do is were placing bee
hives strategically in the field what
happens is that today
beekeepers place behaves when they
provide is pollination service to
farmers they place them in large groups
where it is more convenient to them
actually but the problem is that
beekeepers motivation today is not to
produce more apples per acre their
motivation is their bees
honey and in getting money from from the
Paris right and that's perfect that's
okay that's the way we we manage my
nation for decades and we've lo we
consider that there is an opportunity
for for example placing beehives
strategically in the field to maximize
the trunk the transport of pollen right
and ensure that all the trees get the
amount of pollen they need to maximize
its production you remember that I told
that there are some flowers that depend
on the amount of pollen I bet that was
in the flower it's the amount of seeds
that that are produced on the size of
the fruit so when you go and harvest
let's say an apple tree you have
different sizes or puppets yes and the
reason is because those flowers that
were before the Apple we see less pollen
the others so you can like make an
homogeneous distribution understand bee
fly patterns and how they interact with
flowers you can also maximize fraction
so considering those three things what
we're doing is going to the farmers and
providing what we call the next
generation of pollination services yes
because our best motive our biggest
motivation is increasing yields because
we understand that bees have a lot of
potential but bees together with science
yeah my understanding bees biology we
can make beasts more efficient make them
live longer make them be healthier and
may them be smarter while pollinating a
crop and a hedge the farmer this is so
beautiful with yes thank you so much for
entering this industry and for helping
us with sustainability and with food and
and with overall understanding our world
better okay great so that's B flow and
that is now you guys are how many how
many places are you guys in now we're
working with in Argentina and California
here and we are planning to build our
headquarters and operations here in
California because after in the bio we
found that there's a lot of
opportunities here
California is huge for us it's gonna be
the biggest market in the world here so
we have a small team in Argentina we are
already working with farmers there with
several and some of the biggest
companies in Argentina producing animals
blueberries apples and Kiwis and here we
see a lot of opportunity so so yeah
awesome it is again huge thank you for
everything thank you very much cherry
enjoy it's been such a pleasure thank
you thank you